good morning Millennials welcome back to
the morning toast happy Monday hope
everyone had an amazing weekend for all
of our New York toasters I hope everyone
is doing well after like the tornado
question mark question mark like with no
warning like the weather's always like 6
days there's going to be a tornado 5
days and you know they do weather on the
ones so it's like literally at 11:01
1111 11:21 11:31 they tell you the news
and like literally I'm watching uh Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire last night
which I have many thoughts on and
literally uh it's like
oh there's a tornado and I look outside
and it's so loud there's so much rain
and so much wind and I saw videos of
like trash just being like swept around
the city because of the wind like it was
so strong it's so crazy I didn't get a
warning I didn't see a warning I was
just on my couch reading and then I
heard like buckets being like sashed
against my window and I was like what in
the world and I went out to look and it
was like it was craziness Insanity so I
just was like Bruno I've got you I've
got you pee in the kitchen pee in the oh
for it was a pee in the kitchen day um
also last you saw us Bruno was on the
show I was so distracted because my
sweets was here and I loved having him
here I L that you guys all got to meet
him he probably won't come back for like
six months because it was so distracting
like I couldn't give my best thoughts
and opinions and jokes on the subject
matter because I was like is Bruno going
to be on my lap no I literally remember
like those days and it's really
traumatizing because you're a working
mom now and like you want to be able we
have this this is a a child friendly
it's a family friendly Studio workplace
and as much as like it makes your life
so easy to bring him so you don't have
to leave him it actually makes your life
so much harder no it did not make my
life easy whatsoever and the time that
I'm at the show is like great CR time
for him and it gets him on a really good
schedule for the rest of the day so I'm
glad you guys got to meet him and you'll
see if you want to see him again like
check out my Instagram at Jacko problems
or pups with no job where the content is
premium yeah it's like actually really
sad but puppies do need a good amount of
alone time so they're not like super
dependent on you in my Cavalier book
that I was reading it says that the
puppy should sleep 18 hours a day and
you might feel like that's a lot but
that's what they need for their growth
and it's a lot of change and I feel like
I need to be sleeping 18 hours a day too
no I think I am sleeping 18 hours a day
so I feel like I'm right on track yeah
you're right on track um I want to talk
a little bit about Who Wants To Be A
Millionaire okay you watched is there a
reboot I can't keep up who hosts Jimmy
Kimmel oh I'm sorry and he is what
qualifications I know he's so awful like
I really dislike him and I really feel
like similar to how I felt about David
Letterman which maybe was unpopular I
just feel like these kind of like
straight white men like got famous in an
era when like only straight white men we
like getting famous and getting on TV
and it's like now that we have the
Internet it's like really proving like
how unfunny they are cuz there's like
just so many better people out there and
he was so bad and he was so chatty and
like literally I watched probably the
last 45 minutes I missed like the first
15 minutes last 45 minutes the show
moves so quickly I think I probably saw
six trivia questions like they talk so
much like she had the answer to this the
show moves so slowly yeah you said
quickly oh sorry moves so quickly I saw
slowly oh my God a stroke like literally
mov so
slowly it was just infuriating like
literally it's like one question in like
Jimmy and the girl like were talking
about it for an hour like it was so
boring like well this reminds me of my
child no literally and the woman was um
like a American Sign Language
interpreter so like she was talking like
about how maybe her knowledge of the
signs like could help her with the
answer and it was just so slow like it
was torture and I actually love game
shows and I love trivia like I love Who
Wants To Be A Millionaire and the reboot
is just [__] trash like I mean
everything about it sounds like trash
they should get a different hosting
there cuz it's it's actually such an
amazing concept for a show and I
remember watching it growing up and
there are so many iconic moments and I
feel like caught cheating oh no yeah I
was researching it last night like he
had um someone in the audience cough
when he mentioned the right answer so
he's on the final answer and it's like
it was actually really hard it's like
what number represents like you know 10
with 10 zeros or whatever and it has
like the name the name of the number and
it's a goall and he was like reciting
all the answers and he was like I
definitely don't think it's a googal and
the guy coughed then he's like wait
maybe it is and the the host was really
confused I think it was Who Wants To Be
A Millionaire UK but it's actually
really fascinating that is such a
scandal cuz he won a million dollars
yeah and his wife was there too and it
was like a whole coordinated thing oh my
God honestly that's like kind of
brilliant and the fact that they pulled
it off like and won the game like they
should keep the money like well it
reminded me of Slum Dog Millionaire oh
for sure it was based off of that it's
an amazing movie amazing movie yeah
amazing movie I totally agree um it was
one of those movies that like I didn't
see when it swept the Oscars and I'm
like oh Slum Dog Millionaire is winning
everything and then I watch it I'm like
oh I understand why oh for me it was
like one of the first movies that I saw
that was like of the Oscar season like
and I saw it that year and I was like
well it should win every category it was
the best movie it's also the only the
only one you saw and then you feel like
so proud and like you're liter like a
cheerleader for just that movie I've
been there yeah but I feel like we still
do that to this day 100% except now to
this day I've usually seen like of the
top five or six movies I've seen like
three yeah and that's all you can hope
from us no 100% um but I actually feel
like I learned a lot during my time on
who want to be a millionaire it was just
like random questions like do you know
what um is featured on European
currency on European currency so I'll
give you some of the oh yeah give me the
four choices um it
was inventions
okay architectural buildings
okay um oh like Landscapes okay and I
forget so so three and it's all of all
of Europe European banknotes European
banknotes
inventions I would say the buildings
yeah and also I would say that because
of the way like I just know your brain
you had to cover one first like weren't
going to say the one God that is exactly
what I did you sandwiched the answer in
the middle and then you gave me another
cover [__] am I so easy to read that's
exactly what I did wow I'm shook um yeah
so I didn't know that so I was just like
learning a lot last night you know
that's really interesting I like you're
really educating yourself no I know and
I'm really and like so the first six
questions are like really silly cuz it's
like you went $50 $100 $200 up to ,000
and they're kind of easy and like I dead
ass felt really stupid cuz I did not
know one of them oh and I was watching
with Ben no you really learn a lot about
people when you watch trivia with them
do you know Ben did not know who Amilia
a hurt was wow and and so what is where
is Ben now oh he knows now and he was
like oh yeah like the home no I like I
shamed him out of the house I'm like you
don't know who Amelia aart is take Theo
for a walk but then in his defense I
didn't realize I guess I never put
together that Adam's apple is actually
like a Biblical reference from Adam and
Eve did you know that oh maybe if I had
thought long hard enough about it but no
that's not what I would have thought of
first me neither but it was like which
body part
is from the Garden of Eden oh I didn't
ask I had already shamed him into like
silence that is so funny yeah he's never
going to answer a question again no
never and I just I've always find it
interesting like Ben and I I'm actually
the same way too like I lack so much
basic knowledge like of like things like
I guess everyone knows and that was one
of those things where I'm like you don't
know who Amilia aart is I'm like wow
you're dumb yeah you're were syney oh
totally wow okay I'm loving I'm loving
this trivia Journey for you I love
trivia and I want that to be like my
thing like Oh that girl she's is's like
so triv Tri Queen Tri que she's so
trivial you don't want them to say that
about you I know I know um great well I
had a really great weekend like a really
great mix of plans and no plans balance
I think that's what they would call
balance I read a very good book called
love your life by Sophie canella and I
would recommend it to anyone who's just
like needing a light pickme up who
hasn't read like a a book in a while
that was me and it was just light and
fun and made me laugh a number of times
oh love to see it kind of like girl with
no job by Claud ashre that's I would
describe that book too yeah know me too
for sure and while we're on the subject
of books I'm so glad you brought that up
please head over to girlwith job.com
book or tap the link in my bio on my
Instagram to pre-order my Memoir girl
with no job the crazy beautiful life of
an Instagram thirst monster available at
Barnes & Noble Amazon indiebound the
ebook is available for pre-order the
audio book is available for pre-order it
comes out January 26 2021 and you're
like Claudia why you talking about this
in October I just need good pre-sale
numbers so I can get into airports
that's pretty much the only reason so
check it out girl job.com book I would
really appreciate you know any and all
support love to see it we love to
support you thank you so much I love be
supportive even though last night when
we were FaceTiming you almost lost me as
a fan yeah well Jackie quoted my special
and she just she used the quote wrong
sorry I just like didn't find what I was
saying applicable and it's like you're
going to come for me for supporting you
I wasn't necessarily coming for you I
was just you left me hanging I
definitely left you hanging but um it
was just because I was like so invested
in the crown because that's what I did
last night oh I haven't started the
crown yet that's going to be my activity
today I was just like I wasn't ready and
I didn't want to rush it it's like I've
been waiting so long for this I'm not
going to watch it hastily in the middle
of a book I'm going to take my time with
it like Bruno's never seen the crown so
I have to explain the black story to him
and I just I'm so excited that's going
to be my afternoon today and I'm
thrilled I'm only two episodes in I'm so
excited I too I'm savoring it I'm not
trying to rush through it but you know
I'm actually like not a big fan of like
the Diana years in terms of just like
the monarchy and yeah and pop culture
like I actually and I think I might be
alone and controversial in saying like I
wasn't like a huge Diana fan and I
actually I take the side of the monarchy
like in the monarchy vers Diana I think
I just usually take the side of the mon
um so I'm looking forward to like how
they portray her um because it's one of
two things like was she you know sweet
and innocent or was she like their
sponsor General like we'll see what they
say um so I'm just looking forward and
like if you're a big Diana stand like
you might not like what I have to say
well let's see how it goes how it goes
you'll watch it first I is a carbon copy
the actress it's crazy how much she
looks like Diana the hair is really
triggering for me seen some of the phot
oh I'm
sure that's why okay that's why I don't
like her that's why she doesn't like
it's literally like a bowl cut it's so
bad she literally looks like she's like
an eighth grader in the'80s like I hate
the haircut so much um but it like
that's why I don't understand fashion
because not only is it so ugly it became
the hairstyle like because of her so
maybe it's just like my you know lack of
f fashion sense but it's one of the
ugliest hairstyles I've ever seen in my
life and like I can't understand it
sorry well we appreciate your she like a
child like she goes hunting with Philip
and I'm like that literally looks like
Prince William like when he was a kid
like that's literally the hairstyle he
had I'm so triggered by that hairstyle
oh God I hope you can enjoy the season
nonetheless yeah no I definitely will
it's just so good to have the the G the
game back together oh my God I'm
literally so excited so we'll have a
full recap when we'll finish it at the
same time we'll coordinate we'll finish
it this week yeah we'll finish yeah but
like same day so that can it this is our
last week of Thanksgiving break we're
very excited um so that's just something
exciting usually this time of year we
head out west for Thanksgiving but you
know due to the pandemic we'll not be
there so I am just going to spend more
time in my bed and I think that's great
because I've actually really been
missing my bed yeah and I think your bed
has been missing you yeah definitely for
sure um so in addition to the crown I
also watched pic last night which will
be in our TV recap segment as did I also
have a new episode of the undoing to
watch I didn't watch it last night it's
it's weird for me to be back on a show
that's episodic and like weekly yeah it
feels so unnatural and like I just it's
not enough for me to get by but like
everyone's talking about last night's
episode so before it gets spoiled for me
I just have to watch it when I get home
today got it and I'm going to save it
I've come this far like I'm going to
keep waiting I think I can avoid no
one's really like spoiling and I still
have no idea what it's about like
literally no clue and I'm going to
continue down that path cuz I just want
to treat myself okay so without further
Ado I do believe that it is time for the
fast five stories you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning
toast and yes yes you you didn't lie to
our followers our listeners I would
never you would never I would though um
but I'm not lying when I say that
today's episode is brought to you by
crate Joy the world's first and only
subscription box marketplace where you
can shop over thousands of unique boxes
and gifts for just about anything you
can imagine even better you choose the
subscription length so you're not locked
into just anything crate Joy mixity easy
to find that perfect gift for anyone and
everyone in your life the hardest part
of buying gifts is getting something
cool and unique and crate Joy does all
that with create Joy you'll show you you
you'll show you care with personalized
gifts that keep giving long after the
holidays are done on crate Joy you guys
can find categories that you'll love
like Escape rooms and mystery boxes for
Adventures at home boxes to boost each
version of you with self-care and
personal growth cool cocktail kits and
snacks for your next virtual happy hour
monthly book clubs in a box for every
reader and top DIY and craft kits for
crafts of all ages the whole family kids
the adults CR Joy is the best place to
shop for gifts and with the holidays
right around the corner it's hard to
find great gifts for all the special
people in your life during the holidays
a subscription box is the gift that
keeps on giving so true you know someone
got margar a subscription box it was
like a beauty one for her birthday like
two years ago and I thought it was the
most creative gift it and now cre gift
that keeps on giving because like the
holidays are so exciting you get your
gifts but like to be reminded of that
exciting time every time your
subscription and the person like it's so
warm it's it it will carry you through
the year if you're a people pleaser and
like you really want to overachieve this
year CR Joy is the thing for you it's
the subscription box is the gift that
keeps on giving show how much you care
long after the holidays on crate Joy you
can choose something unique personalized
and memorable for everyone on your list
and if you're looking to give the
perfect give perfect gift or you just
want to treat yourself you can shop
thousands of subscription boxes all in
one place and get 30% off your first box
when you sign up at cratejoy.com toast
that's right sign up today at c r a TJ
y.com toast to get 30% off your first
box and early access to all of crate Joy
holiday specials create Joy get joy
delivered right to your door sign on get
joy also that's a great point that you
made like yes we should be getting gifts
for everyone in our lives it's the
holidays is the season but get a gift
for yourself 100% I think it's so
important to get gifts for yourself and
create Joy is an amazing gift to get for
yourself cuz you'll remember how much
you love yourself every time your
subscription comes and you know what
it's like I have so many people in my
life who love me but who loves me more
than me absolutely nobody no and who
knows what you want better than you
actually I'm very indecisive um it's my
anagram 3 thing so actually I think I
know what you want better than you
1,000% I just like say things and I
forget you know yeah I think we should
normalize getting gifts for ourselves I
think it's been normalized I don't think
you have to like champ sometimes you
need a reminder yes a reminder for sure
so I wonder what I'm going to get myself
this year I'm thinking like I don't know
a jet okay first story The really the
big story from the weekend Olivia wild
and Jason sudakis have ended their
engagement after 7 years their children
are the priority wait were they not
married no they were engaged for 7 years
it was the seven-year engagement
interesting yeah that's always I didn't
realize that beforehand but that's
always like a red flag right and not
that there's anything wrong with not
being married but it's like if you're
getting engaged it's with the purpose of
getting married yeah but you know what
actually I'm taking that statement back
because now that I think about it
sometimes we talk about celebrities who
probably like shouldn't get married for
like legal and financial reasons but
they are life partners and you know you
want to wear a ring so you get engaged
but then you don't get married yeah I I
guess like I think maybe now people who
are just like permanently engaged that's
like the new like partnership you know
yeah and I actually
see complete like the reason why you
would do that and right so I take back
what I said I'm taking it back the
couple share two sons I mean they share
a son Otis Alexander and a daughter
Daisy Josephine I just love those names
me too I actually was really shocked by
this I just kind of there's some people
who are like so cemented in their
relationship that like you legitimately
forget about them no you forget about
them like their ships are out at Sea
they're anchored and they're not coming
in and out of the port you're not
thinking about them there's no real
maintenance and this was one of those
ships and and the ship has Su I just
feel like there are some people in this
world who's like relationship goals were
Olivia wild and Jason City guess and
they're rethinking everything no and I'm
thinking of those people because it can
be a real shock to your system when like
the belief system you built like on love
is like surrounded on like this one
relationship and then it's over you know
no I know and like there are a few
couples where it's like I'm worried if
something ever happens to them cuz for
the people who have like invested so
much in them emotionally and it's like
if these certain couples break up like
love isn't real you know for some people
for some people yes of course but I feel
like this might have been like a like a
real goals couple for like a lot of like
Pinterest like users and I'm just if
you're one of them I'm hoping that
you're okay and I'm just checking in on
you yes well the split happened at the
beginning of the year a source close to
the couple tells people it's been ible
and they've transitioned into a great
co- paring co-parenting routine the
children are the priority and the Heart
of the family's relationship well that's
actually really nice for them that they
you know broke up in the beginning of
the year they figured it all out they're
definitely like in the better place now
and now they're releasing the news and
like they had all this time and space to
be able to do that do you think that
this was a quarantine like result or
like maybe they just weren't bear well
when I hear beginning of the year like I
think January through March right yeah
so that would be I guess not quarantine
right yeah okay I'm just still really
surprised yeah it's it's surprising they
they're like mad cute and I don't know
but then I also just feel like it's
what's best clearly you know it's not
like they didn't give it College try
yeah I just feel like everything
celebrities do these days is just so
predictable so when there's a story that
like legitimately like surprises me and
like catches me off guard I'm like shook
by that feeling you know yeah and when
there's a couple that has managed to
keep their breakup out of the spotlight
for let's say six months also surprising
totally yeah good for them honestly yeah
I feel like um he's not my type but like
feel like people are obsessed with Jason
sedus he gives me Justin Timberlake
Vibes just no don't don't s his name
like that no I'm I'm just saying looks
wise which is like not my type but I
feel like there's a lot of you know
single women who are like really excited
about this you know that's true and I'm
happy for them I'm not one of them but
I'm really happy for you guys I don't
associate him with like the Justin
timberlakes of world oh that's so also
for me like because he's funny like he
goes into like funny guy category and
that automatically makes you more
handsome and that's a great like bin to
be in yeah it's like the Vince Von bin
yeah the Jason seagull bin I love he is
in that bin for me where is he I don't
know he needs to come come out wherever
you are we miss you we miss you like you
just I feel like he made so much money
with um How I Met Your Mother and like
then his iconic movies like he's just
like doesn't need to work but he doesn't
know like the Jason seagull stands are
like so waiting with baited breath and
if you could just like do something for
us like it would mean a lot it would
mean a lot like we could really use that
right now what do you think what was his
last actual like working job well you
know there's one way to find out imtb
literally my best friend and I recently
found out that I've been paying IMDb Pro
$21 a month for like a year I don't even
remember signing up for it you signed up
through your Amazon and I'm like so
upset about it okay so he's currently
filming a movie called The Sky Is
everywhere oh that doesn't sound funny
no and he plays a character named big
[__] yeah [__] that sounds like he's
trying too hard before that in 2020 he
was in The Princess Bride TV series
short I feel like we reported on that
that it was coming and I guess it came
don't remember before that he was in
dispatches from elsewhere again maybe
I'm not a Jason seagull never heard of
these our friend before that come Sunday
before that the discovery before that
the end of the tour he played David
Foster
Wallace is that um the author yeah like
it's not David Foster no no no I didn't
think it was you know he wrote that poem
about telephone polls before that was
the travesty called sex tape oh that was
a Travis D so that really was like his
last work that we would have known got
it okay well um okay he's due for a
comeback just yeah like I it's time I
just feel like he doesn't care like he's
so rich I know but you know like if he's
an artist like the art of course compel
him no artists are so compelling and
they're compelled compelled
right right right no I hear that they
don't just like make art for the profit
some of us to no but then that's not
real art you know oh you know what I beg
to disagree uh I beg to differ sorry um
you really want to disagree yeah no I'm
begging you please disagree with me no
I'm I'm over this whole narrative where
it's like if you want to make money like
you can't be good at your job like why
can't you want both oh my God no that's
really not what I said and I was just
like speaking on behalf of artists I
really wasn't like trying to start with
you yeah no I actually as I was falling
asleep last night I was having this like
argument in my head do you ever like
maybe I'm I'm such just like go through
all my arguments Point by Point kind of
but do you ever like I go through my
arguments but I'm like if I was ever
invited on Joe Rogan like this is what I
would say and like I go through the
interview like in my head about like all
the good points I feel like I make that
like I want to talk to Joe about you
know what I mean
100% And I don't know if that's just cuz
we are who we are but and we we talk for
a livit I feel like people just like
talk to themselves in their heads like
my whole day is just like conversations
with myself that I never have actually
that was a point that we made from one
of our books in the redheads it was like
she it was actually a terrible not a
terrible book but it was a little above
our P but she it was from glass Hotel
she was like had a long lost friend or
relative or something that she had
argued within her head so many times so
that by the time they got to the point
of the conversation it was like so easy
cuz she had said everything a million
times that's funny you know what I mean
so that's what I feel like it is like
even if it's just like a friend or
something you're always just like going
over your points in your head oh and I'm
the of like going over points in my head
700 times and then like when it comes to
the conversation I'm
like I love you s I'm sorry I didn't
mean it no literally like I'm the worst
people just assume that because I'm like
really like extroverted and like chubby
that I'm like I like live for
confrontation and I [__] hate
confrontation like I'm actually like I
will I'm so conflict diverse like I will
do anything like not to have an
uncomfortable conversation but people
are always trying to start with me cuz
they just think it's like what I want
you know know cuz I give off that energy
maybe people are trying to start with
you cuz like they have something to say
to you no I don't think so I don't think
so damn okay well condolences to um the
sedus wild wild stands and also now
they're two interesting aess people back
on the market look forward to seeing
what they do next wait actually just one
more thing about this um who did you
think of when you heard that these
people broke up like do you have like a
friend who's like like their like their
go-to couple is like Jason sudas and
Olivia wild well no but we have a friend
who for some reason just reminds me of
Jason sudakis well I know what the
reason is Kristen and Pete they do yeah
just I like it's a long story but they
just remind me of Jason I like
immediately thought of my friend Abe
who's like obsessed with Jason Zas and
like thinks Olivia Wild's like the
hottest girl who ever walked the Earth
and I'm like I'm worried about him today
I'm going to have to call
him I'm going to have to call him today
just to like check in check in on your
friends like who are standing Olivia
wild because they're not okay yeah and
also just check in on your friends
period yeah please check in on
me next up speaking of some relationship
news Taylor Swift says Joe alwin
absolutely understands how Fame affects
their privacy Taylor Swift and boyfriend
Joe alwin's Lack of privacy and their
relationship was the inspiration behind
one of her new songs and it happens to
be uh Claudia Ash's favorite song from
the new album peace is this from the
interview with the Paul McCartney cover
Paul McCartney okay first of all if you
haven't listened to pece by Taylor I
know it's like if you hate tell you
think you're cool just listen to the
song like it'll make you cool the song
sh told told Paul McCartney in their new
cover story for Rolling Stone that the
effort she made to give her current bow
a sense of normaly was a challenge she
worked to
overcome peace is actually more rooted
in my personal life she said to
McCartney I know you have done a really
excellent job of this in your personal
life carving out a human life within a
public life and how scary that can be
when you do fall in love and you meet
someone especially if you met someone
who has a very grounded normal way of
living without outright naming Joe Swift
discussed the tune piece in the context
of the relationship she's in now they
have been linked since spring 2017 and
are notoriously private well I guess
it's been three years now since they've
been together I like forget that she has
a boyfriend because they're so private
yeah but we always knew piece was about
just that so it's always nice to get
confirmation on the the theories oh yeah
and it's actually like the premise of
the song is actually really sweet like
I'm sure being Taylor shi's boyfriend
has like amazing benefits like the
planes and all that stuff but it's got
to be quite difficult sometimes and I
feel like that song that she wrote is
like so beautiful it's like an apology
like sorry my life is so messy but then
it's like even if she was a regular girl
like everyone's life no one has peace
there's always ups and downs yeah um but
I actually really liked the concept that
uh Rolling Stone did with those covers
there was like three different covers
with three like kind of new contemporary
and like older um musicians like banded
together and you know I saw Paul
McCartney at dinner like two weeks ago
did you say hi no he is so old like I've
like he so old looking I don't know how
old he is in real life but well there's
one way to find out Claudia oh my God
Jackie like gets an iPad once like I
know cuz everyone's like hold on he is
78 yeah I was getting more like 88 vibes
okay that's always what you want to hear
yeah no he was really giving me like
remember when we used to uh go to the
country club in Florida with our
grandparents yes like everyone was a
raisin like that was the vibe got it
yeah got it okay well next story um some
interesting news oh wait sorry is it the
next story brought to you by love book
oh my God yes actually it is it really
is what are the odds right in the nick
of time love book is a personalized gift
that helps people express feelings that
might be difficult to say out loud most
customers use a love book to revisit
their Fondest Memories or to list the
reasons why they love someone love books
are completely customizable and people
can use them to share whatever they want
if you want to share an example to
someone of like how much they mean to
you you want to put photos write poems
it's like such a really unique gift and
I feel like for the holiday season
certain people like they're actual
people like who material items like are
so much less important than like knowing
that they're loved and having more like
special gifts and love book is one of
the things I always get DMS about what
was the love book code what was the love
book code pay attention please you guys
can create characters that look just
like you or the recipient someone in
your family with all the different
features that make them unique and then
you can even choose their hairstyle like
you can get really specific
and customers have the option to
personalize each page as much as they
like but they also have an Express
option where you can create a book in
like a minute like it takes super fast
um if you're in a rush love books are
the perfect gift for any occasion but
especially for anniversaries birthdays
Christmas Hanukkah Quanza um if you've
been looking to get something special
for someone really important in your
life um this is like a really just
really special unique gift and you can
go to lovebookonline.com toast to
receive a special 20% discount for just
the toasters so lovebookonline.com toast
to receive a special 20% discount it's
really unique it's really special you
can customize it like down to every
detail or you can use the custom uh
Express order and get it done in just a
few minutes but I really feel like it's
fabulous and people are always asking
about the code such a special gift to
give someone that you love who Treasures
like uh sentimental sental gifts and I
couldn't recommend it highly me too
lovebookonline.com toast you know who
would love a love book who Chloe
Kardashian she would she 100% would and
she's moving out of her magical
Calabasas home bye-bye beautiful this is
crazy this is crazy because she has
lived there for a really long time I
feel like a lot of the other sisters
have moved around a lot but she has
lived there for a while and didn't she
just renovate it remember she had to
rent because she was renovating it oh
very very true and she just had the home
at it come to her garage like what was
the point I mean who knows I I'll be so
curious to see where she moves next but
the home sold for
$15.5 million which is more than double
the 7 .2 million she paid for it 6 years
ago wow what look at this investing
Queen also this home is so rich in
history it used to belong to Justin
Bieber before her and then before that
it was uh belonged to the ex-wife of
Eddie Murphy Nicole Murphy wow I just
feel like this home has really good
vibes energy and I feel like every time
we've seen it on the show I love chlo's
decorating style and I feel like that's
also why it sold for a lot like with all
the furniture like look at this fire pit
we've seen it on the show but like
doesn't that just look like a dream no
Chloe's Furniture and Design aesthetic
is like oversized luxury oversized
Comfort like every chair is enormous
every couch is enormous her bed is
[__] huge like I if I was like super
super rich like I would have Chloe's
like everything like I would buy
everything that she has 100% also like
the fact that we saw her bedroom so much
in this most recent season of Keeping Up
with the Kardashians and the fact that
she has a living room in her bedroom
with like big chairs and a fireplace
like was just nuts nuts interesting real
estate fact to it is that the estate now
holds the record for the highest price
per square foot of any home ever sold in
calabases wow look at Chloe I'm so shook
I know and I really feel like it has to
do with what we've been saying about her
style of home like and all the
renovations she did yeah just like who
wouldn't want to move into that
beautiful beautiful house and I feel
like homes that have like Rich celebrity
history like in calabas is like always
just go yeah like what what what like
non-f famous rich person like doesn't
want to live in Chloe Kardashian's house
no I have no clip like I would invite
all my friends over and like sniff the
sheets like totally guys this is where
Chloe farted like let's sniff it sniff
wait this I just like I don't know why I
find this so interesting no me too and I
also can't help but think about where
she's going to be moving I feel like
she's like moving down the block for
sure but like maybe an even bigger
crazier more beautiful home if possible
you know what I actually found really
interesting on this most recent episode
of Keeping Up with the Kardashians when
they did the driveby for uh Courtney's
birthday party how like Courtney and I
thought this before they only show
Courtney's home from the back but when
they do the Drone and they go above the
house you can see she actually lives
really really close to her neighbors
like there was a home right across
justock they estat ands of are but
there's like it's like a c sack there's
like a house next that is interesting on
in the drive by party it did look like
you know was
serone but from the back it's like a
whole thing yeah I just found that
interesting like Courtney Kardashian has
like neighbors who like legit live a
Stones throw away yeah that is
interesting yeah just not what I
expected also you know Kim doesn't have
neighbors you know what else is oh my
God Kim I don't think Chris either cuz
she has that long driveway like they
actually you know they really pulled a
fast one on us with Chris Jenner's home
yeah they show us a different house they
don't show us that the outside anymore
um but they used to show us that like
brown house which was like not even
remotely it I don't even think that
house is like in California like it was
just so not it and then I feel like they
made it seem like she moved but her
house her kitchen looks the same yeah
but also where she's been filming like
these quarantine scenes it feels like
it's almost like a guest house yeah and
it's so like Airy oh that's a totally
different house you're right you're
right she definitely did move cuz she
did architectural digest and that was
like not even that was not the checkered
floors right but then someone actually
like sent me this picture from Rob's
profile where he was in the checkered
floor to staircase like people think
maybe he maybe moved in there that house
there's something they definitely didn't
sell that house it's like I I feel like
they really regret selling their
original home like that ranch because
that's like a piece of Pop Culture
history and now the second home with a
checkered floor where Jennifer Lawrence
came you know like that's a piece of Pop
Culture history too and I don't think
they should or would ever sell it yeah
but I don't think Chris lives there
fulltime but now I'm saying like
allegedly perhaps there's a chance that
Rob's living there yeah and with the
quarantine stuff Kim and the kids like
walked across the street to um Chris's
house remember to get Cheetos so I feel
like whatever
neighborhood Kim is in Chris is in too
yeah which is like the Richer richer
part of like Hidden Hills Calabasas I
think Chloe and Courtney live really
really close to each other cuz they both
have neighbors which Kim and Chris do
not and I have no idea where Kylie lives
cuz we like never oh she just moved into
that she just got her new house Fortress
Is that in Calabasas no it's like it was
in the valley like yeah it was like out
it was like that's why we we spoke about
it was like 30 minutes out of Calabasas
interesting yeah but Kylie's like a
woman of she does her own thing and
she's also like out on the town
constantly like her living an hour away
like up north from like the life of
Hollywood the life of Kylie it doesn't
work for a 22-year-old but for Kim who's
40 like it's lovely lovely and who has a
million kids exactly I could talk about
Kardashian real estate like all day like
remember that house that Rob and chy
were living in that like Chris bought
for them yeah that was such a weird time
in pop culture like it was when Chris
was just like trying hard to like make
it all work I mean that's what she does
that's what she does okay in next story
some exciting happy couple news that
also is just like a marker of time okay
love is blinds Lauren speed and Cameron
Hamilton and Amber and Barnett are
celebrating their second w at
anniversaries okay did anyone else feel
like we watched Love is Blind in
quarantine like I we watched it the week
before quarantine literally because when
Cameron and Lauren came on our show it
was like in March it was and I
remembered like we were when they came
the studio years because they build a
year before it oh I'm sorry okay that
makes more sense because I'm thinking
I'm like this show did not air two years
ago but it filmed two years ago two
years ago they got married two years ago
so it's just like really interesting and
we have two happy couples celebrating
wedding an I mean Lauren and Cameron are
like the least surprising thing ever
like they're so meant to be true love
but I did not have high hopes for Amber
and Barnett like I thought that they
would fizzle out quite fast and they're
actually very cute yeah they are very
cute all four of them are and you would
think like being in a new relationship
is hard especially when you met on a
reality show and there are so many
things that even after you've gotten
married like you need to work out with
your partner plus like one year into
marriage you go into quarantine together
like that is just so crazy but I'm glad
to see that all of these couples are
doing so well no it makes me really
happy too are there any Couples from too
hot to handle no no because I think the
only ones who yeah Franchesca and Harry
but they're definitely not together not
together um so this is just really
shocking I actually loved Love is Blind
I thought it was like such an
interesting premise for a reality show
it was also like cringy and amazing
which is what makes it great but I also
think like the experiment behind it was
actually interesting like is love blind
interesting human experiment and I think
it is yeah I agree I think it can be I'm
really happy for them actually you know
Amber came up on my Tik Tok for you page
she was going off like replied to this
comment cuz someone was like aren't you
the girl who's like husband had to bail
her out of like student loan debt and
she just like went off on like how she
got herself into debt and like Barnett
has debts too and like she's since Paid
It Off by herself and like [__] off like
I'm sure that's like the one comment she
gets like people are always like to me
like why don't you we say Yes to the
Dress dress for your wedding and I'm
sure like for her it's like 10 times
worse and like that's what she always
gets like did you ever pay off like your
$700 Ulta Bill like that's literally
what it was that's probably what she
gets like all the time and it's it's 2
years now it's like [__] off like and so
I actually really loved her response she
went off on this Tik Tok but it's
probably annoying as [__] yeah for sure
like uh everyone in America has
debt get over it get over it um yeah so
I just think that's really interesting
news two years married for these couples
it is a interesting marker of time
that's that's exactly what it is and our
fifth and final story is um your daily
Nathan aoda update oh my God I'm so
excited what happened now the viral
dream skateboarder has 320,000 reasons
to smile because he has a new home that
he paid $320,000 in cash for it's a
five-bedroom three-b crib wow in Idaho
Falls wow five bedrooms in Idaho for
$320,000 we got to move we got to move
yeah oh my God every time I hear an
update on this guy I fall more and more
in love with him and I think he's
literally turning into America
sweetheart like I don't know I just
someone who rises to fame so quickly
makes like a lot of money really quickly
and doesn't just like move to LA and
like start dating Instagram models like
I don't know it's it's just so rare so
the fact that like he
literally got so famous like proposed to
his longtime girlfriend and I like
bought a house in his hometown like we
have absolutely no choice but to stand
this role model like we have no choice
but to stand this is so beautiful like
this is just the definition of a story
that keeps getting betterer dream it
really really is and it's like the going
viral it's the it's the 2020 American
Dream 100% And like he's really really
famous I saw him he shot a commercial
with Snoop Dog like he's really getting
up there he's going to be in a Super
Bowl commercial 100% for who I'm not
sure yet oh duh oh my God that'll be
good and if and if they don't make like
if they don't take the opportunity like
Ocean Spray like I'll be really
disappointed yeah and if they don't then
like I don't know minute Mage should and
can I tell you what I learned about
oceans spray I think someone posted in
one of the toast Facebook groups and why
it's like so wonderful that like this
viral moment happened for Ocean Spray
because yes Ocean Spray is like this big
Corporation but it's actually like the
biggest Coalition of farm fers um like
in the country so it's like the
company's made up of 700 like
family-owned farms and like like the
board I don't know how it works but it's
like it's not a typical corporation like
it's actually like a farmers Coalition
and like it's just and they all send in
their cranberries something like that
you know and they all like run the
company together I'm I'm not entirely
sure how it works but it's beautiful
yeah right so it's like it's not
corporate greed like the farmers are
winning yeah and we we love to see
Farmers winning we love to see Farmers
winning we are
farmers
bu happy for them anyways that's your
latest update on Nathan apoda and we
promise to never stop updating you
because I'm just until like he doesn't
become relevant like I will be talking
about him forever I'm just no and I just
we need to thank TMZ for constantly
giving us these updates it's always TMZ
who's like with your latest Nathan aaka
te random tidbit of information yeah
definitely I just I hope that he stays
famous forever and like just keeps on
winning 100% all you can hope for
someone um so we have our Real
Housewives of pic recap which yes they
have been uh teasing you know Ashley
telling Candace about the statement for
two weeks now and we still didn't get it
and we still didn't get the statement so
frustrating we'll get into it our TV
recap segment is brought to you by Jenny
Kane Jenny Kane's secret to an
effortless and elevated home and
wardrobe is timeless Classics and
inviting neutrals that focus on Comfort
without sacrificing style Jackie and I
both received pieces from Jenny and Kane
first of all the packaging was just
Elite like it really felt like you were
opening up like a Christmas miracle I
got this amazing cardigan So Soft so
flattering so cute and cardigans are so
in right now thanks tell Swift for sure
I got an amazing white sweater which I'm
just like I'm feeling is my vibe like I
love a winter white and the quality of
the sweater is like so delicious and
creamy and I cannot wait to wear it and
it's getting so cold that like you
really need statement pieces that going
to keep you warm that are going to keep
you warm Jenny Kane believes in creating
everyday pieces that are made to last
forever polished Basics and home pieces
that will never go out of style we never
go out of from wardrobe Essentials to
everything that make you feel makes your
face sorry from wardrobe Essentials to
everything that makes your space feel
like home these are Timeless pieces that
everyone will love curated Staples for
looking and feeling your best no matter
the occasion you might already have a
favorite Kashmir sweater or well-worn
pair of boots but if it doesn't make you
say I'll never take this off it isn't
Jenny Kane they have tons of signature
pieces mules the Chelsea and can the
Chelsea and Canyon boots that come in
leather suede boiled leather and
shearling and their fisherman in cocoon
cashmere and cotton pieces Jenny cane is
everything of the sort perfect for a
gift but also like we were just saying
treat yourself like get yourself a nice
cashmere spider for the holiday season
like you deserve it you've had a hard
year find your Forever pieces at
jenny.com and get 20% off your first
order when you use code toast at
checkout so that's j nni k a y ne.com
promo code toast check it out holiday
season as they say as G Judi says it's a
season of joy joy sign on never go out
of style works for me Jenny Kane okay
real house of bomac so this trip
actually looks super fun and I really
was getting annoyed that like I knew we
weren't going to get that black latex
moment between Candace [__] you Ashley
[__] you like I I just I can't believe
how long they've been teasing it I was
at like the 45 minute Mark and I'm like
it hasn't happened yet yeah and it's not
going to happen we didn't even get to
that party yeah there was a lot of like
stuff leading up there was also like a
lot I realized of like scenery like
they're doing like so much they're just
no no not even that like where you know
they usually like do a drone over
Portugal and then we zoom into to the
women there's just like so much like
stff b-roll exactly which it's like it's
nice to see Portugal but I do feel like
they're dragging out this conversation
100% And just two things that happened
this episode that made me take note and
they happened at the end of the episode
one Robin and the hats and the model and
leaving Karen out when like Karen's
photos were no better or worse than
anyone else's when they put them up on
the screen I'm like what am I missing
these hats are ugly but the photo's fine
the photo is fine the one where she was
turned to the side like against the wall
like perfectly fine like the fact that
she can't have it on her website in that
next week like caren's going to have to
like be like where's my pH it was like
so cruel I thought I agree and like
Robin like that's what you're
contributing to the season like you've
literally been mute all season so
irrelevant and now you're going to start
drama with Karen over a hat where like
literally you're making such a mountain
of M Hill like there was nothing wrong
with that picture there was nothing
wrong with that picture there was
nothing so spectacular about the other
girls photos that like Cen wouldn't fit
in with theirs I thought it was like
mean girl so mean going out of your way
going out of their way to be mean and
like jezelle being like well it's cuz
like she's not hip like neither are
those you're truly one neither are those
hats no Gizelle is really gelle has
incredible hpah to talk about anyone
else's style because the ponytail that
she was wearing all episode was horrible
and that dress no it it gets worse every
single episode like it really does there
have been some really funny memes like I
guess like now we're all just like
talking about no the Bic audience has
really just openly embraced on gazelle's
terrible style choices and I actually
want to support Robin in this adventure
because I want her to be successful like
she's been through a lot but it just
really rubbed me the wrong way and then
in her professional she's like I really
don't want to like do this to Karen it's
like so then don't do it cont it's not
like the photo was so bad like where
they're all
blurry or like the screen the lens
cracked like no it's a standard picture
the hats are ugly like none of the other
photos were that great like we're really
getting specific here she's going out of
her way to make it seem like this photo
is so much worse there was nothing there
she's being mean to Karen and I now
found myself being so incredibly
defensive of Miss Karen Huger like I
stand until the day I die the only thing
I didn't agree with her on this episode
was constantly bringing up Juan
proposing because if jelle's giving her
the heads up like shut the [__] up
there's like something going on like
that you don't need to know but just
like stop bringing it up a good friend
knows like not to bring it up well I
don't think she brings it up again after
that I just don't think she knew what
she was doing before but I also like
couldn't keep up with what people knew
and what people didn't know and also
like I just don't care about yeah no I
know I just I agree though the the Hat
thing was like really going out of your
way to be mean like really really mean
now I'm also it's crazy how most of the
time I'm like very steadfast in my
housewife beliefs like if I love you I
love you even if you wrong me like I'll
still love you but I think this is been
like a really transitional season for me
and when I think about how far I've come
like at the beginning of bomac I
literally hated Ashley Derby and I
[__] hated Karen Huger so much and I
really like stand Jazelle and I lowkey
like loved Candace and now I am so
turned like it's literally the opposite
like I think Ashley Derby is one of the
best Housewives ever like she really
lays it out she's always involved in the
drama but she's always knows how to like
move past it like I just think she's
amazing and I think Karen Huger is like
so wise like I really like want to
Nestle Nestle my like
face in her neck and just like go to
sleep like I just really like trust her
and I can't stand jaelle I think she's
like actually one of the meanest girls
I've ever met in my life and cannot
stand Candace for obvious reasons I
completely agree and I pretty much agree
with you CU in the beginning like I was
totally team Jazelle and now I'm totally
not but I've always really liked Ashley
I I've always thought she contributed so
much to the show and and now just seeing
her like in this new role where she's
like kind of wiser and more
compassionate like I'm just like I love
this for her and I love to see the
growth she's younger than everyone so
she like her and Candace like both kind
of have like a little bit more growing
up to do and I feel like the Ashley
Darby we know now is like so much more
mature than the Ashley Darby we knew
like 5 years ago and I just am loving
her journey I love growth I think we are
all entitled to it and like I just love
I love to see it I do as well so that
brings me to the second critical thing
that happened in this episode which was
the Ashley jezelle and Robin sitting by
the pool Ashley telling them she wrote a
character statement and I just thought
this this scene like was just so telling
like first of all Jazelle and Robin like
really they were like so shook by it
because they really thought that they
were going to get rid of Mo'Nique with
this like they were so here like
cheering on can even the fight cheering
on K is taking down Monique like just
how dare she how dare she like just
making it so much of a bigger deal than
it taking such a moral High Ground such
a moral High ground and like just not
even associating with Mo'Nique but like
now Mo'Nique is is fighting back which
she has every right to do and they're
like watching how it's going to turn
like swing the other way and they're
like how could you what do you mean how
could you she's just saying like what
her experience has been also when Robin
was like well why couldn't you just
write a statement for Mo'Nique saying
that Mo'Nique is a good friend and a
good mom like the courts don't care what
your friend thinks about you know and
that's not what they ask for like that's
why that cuz that wouldn't do anything
that wouldn't help Monique literally
like I just I was I wasn't surprised by
uh Robin and jelle's reaction cuz
they're just like so steadfast in their
support for C it was just like so
interesting to watch them like so shook
so shook because they they're so here
for Candice like coming for Mo'Nique in
every way and like really to the point
where where Mo'Nique will end up off the
show which is what they always wanted
yeah I don't I mean it's tough for her
to like remain relevant when like she's
literally not on the trip but I actually
don't think that she will be off the
show I don't think so either and even
though she's not on the trip like is she
getting paid for these
episodes I I think she has like a I
think you you get you get paid per
episode and the assumption is that
everyone's in every episode right I
think she might still be getting paain
for them to talk about her yeah I mean I
don't know um where we're going to go
with casting after this I don't think we
could really
ever have a season again with both
Candace and Mo'Nique I don't think
Monique's going anywhere like I don't
know if that's crazy I actually think
Candace has a higher chance of getting
fired than Mo'Nique does I totally agree
and a lot of lot of the Bravo fans are
really upset with Candace Candace is Her
Own Worst Enemy because she might in
certain scenarios like have you know
some ground to stand on when it comes
like arguments with some of the ladies
but what she pulls on social media is so
childish and is so sophomoric like she
gets herself into so much trouble like
even when every time they repopulate
those tweets she sent about Ashley like
bed wench like saying the most evil
things like she's Her Own Worst Enemy
and now she's under Fire because I sent
you this video I don't know if you
watched it she did an an Instagram live
like talking [__] about this Bravo like
blogger who like blogs a lot about about
Atomic I had never heard of him
basically like saying such evil evil
things like I hope he drops dead his
heart Fails Like clogged arteries and
literally most very recently he actually
passed away what so this videos going
around of her like right before he died
like saying awful things about how she
wish she'd like just like a blogger like
a fan of the show like nothing crazy
like she's just going after him and it
actually turns out that he passed away
recently like I went down this rabbit
hole on Tik Tok you know really scary so
a horrible story so she's just Her Own
Worst Enemy cuz yes technically Monique
was the aggressor in the fight yes but
also it's like what you do on the show
you can always make the argument that
like it's for the show you know no and
like that yeah you know I got loud or
this or that but like we're on a show
like that's what we're here to do but
when you take it to those sorts of
levels off the show you have absolutely
like no recourse and it's just you like
like sh your true colors yeah on another
level yeah no she's she says the most
horrible thing on social media and like
I kind of am with Ashley like I know
we're on a show and like we were
supposed to move past this but I'm
actually still really upset about all
the mean things you said about me like
sorry I haven't moved past it but I
tried no 100% And also it's so funny cuz
so much of Candace's like storyline this
season is like not only did Mo'Nique do
what she did but like then she was on
Instagram like you know giving emojis to
people it's like she did emojis no
you're literally so much worse like look
in the mirror and I just really felt
Ashley when it's like you know Candace
doesn't care about what anyone's going
through and then it's like Candace is
like I want to have a baby and
everyone's supposed to be like Yay this
great we'll be there for you when it's
like you just say awful things about
everyone anytime they open up about
anything so it's like we're just
supposed to be like turn around and be
happy for you no also Ashley and Candace
had like buried part of their Hatchet
for sure but they never really discussed
like the way that Candace came for
Ashley when she was starting her
motherhood Journey like even though yes
they've gotten past some of their issues
like what Ashley was bringing up that
last night at dinner was like all new
stuff that really ground that hadn't
been covered yet so I didn't feel like
she was going back over it I actually
thought she made really poignant points
like oh so now you know like now you are
exactly where I was last year and
imagine if I wasn't supporting you and I
want to support you because like I
that's I right but like just see how it
feels also Candace like every time when
she's like you know when she said
something this last night where it was
like after the trauma with Mo'Nique like
I didn't know if I would like something
about like still wanting to be a mom and
it's like are you the more dramatic she
makes it like the the less the less I'm
on her side I think that let's like I
just don't believe anything she says
anymore it's like literally it's been
three seasons of like I'm going to get a
dog I'm going to have a baby I'm going
to sing a song it's like come up with
some new stuff like no I totally agree
like stop talking about it just be about
it it yeah wow she's not the most
anointed one talking actually like I'm
so over jaelle but I love her I mean
word on the street I'm the word on the
street I I just like love her St her um
taglines and you know who's really been
killing not only the um confessional
looks but the confessional shade is Miss
Karen Huger like
she's just a queen no she's such a queen
so when she's disrespected it really
like it hurts it hurts yeah and she's
you know she's the oldest one in the
group and like nobody respects her but
that means something like to me you know
and it's she doesn't get any respect let
alone the respect that she deserves and
when that happens like it really does
bother me and so next week with the hats
in the website like I'm ready I really
hope she says like I don't care like
it's really not a big deal no I hope she
says like oh I don't care because your
hats are hideous and I was just trying
to be good friend to you but never mind
that yeah on to the next one and I just
really hope she doesn't like make Robin
think like Robin like no Robin has this
like she has her website and like she
thinks that there's like power there and
like she's wielding it like I'm going to
let you in on the website oh no I'm not
and it's like I just want her to know
like nobody cares I yeah I hope Karen
plays it that way but I I know that
Karen will be hurt of course I hope that
she like but then also it's like with
the housewife sometimes like the bigger
the victim you are like the more you get
like sympathy so oh if she like you know
always says to C says to Robin like you
hurt my feelings then all of a sudden
like everyone's on Karen's side so also
the only other thing I wanted to say is
I usually think those like pre-planned
pranks are so stupid but I was actually
hysterically laughing when Wendy uh
pulled up her covers and the snakes are
there like that was very genuine and
very funny and I loved them breaking the
fourth wall and showing the girls
watching on the monitor outside in the
hallway hysterical very good stuff very
good stuff yeah um so hopefully next
week we'll get the conversation between
Candace and Ashley about the statement
I'm not sure but I actually think but I
thought so last week too no yeah I don't
know where else we could go without that
conversation but um other than that it
was a pretty good episode and tonight
there's nothing on right I know but then
I actually I can't believe I'm going to
say this like I miss I miss Bachelor on
Mondays like I'm ready for it back yeah
because then when it's on Tuesdays then
it's like Tuesday Wednesday Thursday
there's so much the week is just like so
ramped up yeah I agree I don't I I think
once Dancing with the Stars ends it
Bachelorette will be moved back one day
I think that's how it works I don't know
got it um but work in programming so I'm
not sure um that's all we got you know
what that that leave space for us to
watch the crown tonight yes and that's
exactly what I'll be doing once I upon
arrival to my home um anything else you
want to say before we wrap up um no just
like I love t h EO I love BR Ru o I love
y you oh my god and I love all of you
guys thanks for morning toes W you on
drugs are you okay no I just like love
you all so much me best friends friends
forever thank you guys so much for
listening to the morning to us millenni
Morning Show where we deliver the past
five stories every Monday through Friday
on YouTube so if you're watching us on
YouTube please feel free to subscribe
and give this video a thumbs up we're
also available as a podcast anywhere
podcast can be found so that's Spotify
iTunes stit public radio IH Radio cast
boox all the places soever you listen to
podcast find us the morning chos and
leave a five star riew about how
beautiful stunning and smart Theo is we
hope you have an amazing day we will see
you tomorrow bye goodbye goodbye goodbye
goodbye goodbye sweet
[Music]
goodbye